no one can beat you at being you and as
i've embraced my
weirdness and the fact that i don't
necessarily fit into an archetype as
tons and tons and tons of people do
they all feel this and they nerf the
edges they round off the edges of the
interesting stuff that they do in life
to try and make themselves fit into the
bell curve of what normal is
if you're trying to be normal by
definition you're regressing to the mean
normal people get normal results
extraordinary people get extraordinary
results we all want
somehow everybody wants to both be the
most popular
most liked person on the planet and also
elon musk or conor mcgregor or
one of the kardashians or something and
you think you don't get it both ways
those people have ridiculous outcomes
because they have ridiculous inputs you
can choose one but you can't choose both
this year's been a year of living kind
of groundhog day over and over again
it doesn't matter how varied your life
is everyone in one form or another has
had the guard rails brought in on
variety
in life and i think what that can cause
you to do
is probably get into in the same way as
you get into lifestyle patterns
habitually you get into thought patterns
as well
and that includes narratives around how
you
see things going just how you perceive
stuff i walked back into my house
when i got here and i looked at the
kitchen and the kitchen looked different
like it actually looked like the
dimensions of things were different i
was like has something been moved in
here
and it worked out that i hadn't but it
had been the best part four weeks since
i'd seen it
and there's a concept that the sas use
called a break point
and it's the moment before they will
breach a door
so they'll get stuck up outside of the
door and that break point there is where
they kind of rest reset
and plan to go in and uh i kind of
considered that trip out to dubai as a
little bit of a break point
i like that it's cool concept isn't it
yeah
but anyway we're rolling so charlotte
fox webber welcome welcome
back you are so much less super pregnant
than the last time that we spoke
it's a pleasure to be here and i'm i'm
happy to
not be pregnant although i have a
beautiful baby from it you gotta you got
a baby out of it yeah but you're just
like now half the size
thank you uh so what are we doing today
you wanted to do this thing you said i
have an idea for an episode i want to
come on and talk
absolutely i i have a real interest in
understanding the
life of a podcaster and you're a
particularly good one i shouldn't
just generalize it as a life of a
podcaster because
there are so many and that that doesn't
narrow it down enough you
ask exceptional questions you are
constantly curious i would say curiosity
must be a driving force for you
what is it like to be a question asker
a seeker a constant conversationalist i
want to get into your mind i'm
i'm curious for what it says about you
psychologically
um i think that there are certain
similarities between
how you approach things and and my work
as a psychotherapist
trying to understand inquiring probing
looking at what's underneath
engaging intensely wholeheartedly um
but it can also be a way of avoiding
and not disclosing so i'm here to
challenge you in a way because we've
we've had some
very interesting exchanges and
conversations
and i just want to turn it around
because that's what i do
that sounds good yeah i uh i'm not sure
what i'm in for today but yeah let's get
started let's do this okay
you can always tell me when i'm pushing
too much and
and you don't have to say anything you
don't want to say so
what is it like to constantly ask
questions
that's an interesting one when i was in
dubai recently
we were me and a friend that was out
there with george we were
at a party that was very very not
socially distanced at a
around a pool with a few hundred people
and three different sets of people said
the
same thing to both of us and they asked
us
separately why are you asking so many
questions in a kind of a suspicious way
the first thing that i identified was
that we asked a lot of questions because
curious
the second thing was that in a place
like dubai which is
perhaps a little bit showy and to do
with wealth it's obvious that the game
of tennis that people play when they
converse
is i'm waiting for you to finish saying
your thing so i can say my thing
um being honest i was probably quite a
selfish conversationalist
for a long time and it's been
trained into me that actually in a
conversation the most selfish thing that
you can do is ask questions because you
don't know what the other person knows
you only know what you know
so by asking questions you elicit very
interesting stories
um i tweeted something today actually
about the fact that
people who think they're introverts
might not be introverts they might just
have friends that suck
and i certainly notice i i ask fewer
questions when i'm with people that i'm
not really that interested in what they
have to say
which sounds sounds kind of terrible but
makes also
makes sense like you're not going to dig
as hard in a gold mine that you don't
believe there's any gold in
right um so yeah i certainly have
cultivated that
and i think weaponizing curiosity or
that's not right disciplining curiosity
into a effective
mode of discourse is something that i've
really really enjoyed doing and it's
kind of been stepped up especially this
year
and i really feel that it's an art form
like the art of asking good questions
without breaking the flow and without
sort of losing where you're at
and guiding the person that you're with
has made for
outside of the show it's made for some
of the deepest connections that i've
ever had
me and my friend again george we did
this flight out to dubai and from
amsterdam to dubai is seven hours on the
nose and
we didn't stop speaking for the entire
way there and
wow just us asking like we went from
our sex robots ethical to what's the
future of bitcoin
to like everything and there's this poor
poor girl
uh sat behind him who must have been the
only british person probably within
about three meters
and uh she didn't have any headphones
and she must have been thinking just
shut the [ __ ] up because to everyone
else it's just foreign language noise
but to her she was probably hearing our
sex robot bitcoin myriad discussion so
yes
that's it i enjoy it i enjoy asking
questions and it's something that i wish
i'd known a lot
a lot sooner that it makes for great
connections great friendships and a
wonderful conversation
fascinating how old were you when you
really discovered
the value of asking questions only
really since doing this show
um you mentioned curiosity earlier on
which
is the first of my five core values and
for everyone who hasn't gone and done it
yet google taylor pearson core values
and the exercise will take
you a couple of hours but it's been one
of the most
important things i've done this year
which is to identify what my life is
built around in terms of values
spells out a word the word is cases and
the c in cases
is curiosity so curious i relate to that
do you oh as a therapist a professional
psychotherapist for many many years
there's nothing worse than a therapist
who lacks curiosity
be interested can he be a therapist
without
having curiosity i mean you shouldn't be
right yes and it's a sign of something
it can be a real sign of burnout as well
i i think curiosity is a huge energy
source
yeah that's interesting so
tell me how you feel when people ask you
questions does it ever kind of
make you feel uncomfortable or turn the
spotlight
on you in an awkward way not really
i think for a long time again only child
background
and then coming into doing this sort of
a
an industry i've always been used to
having at least some form of center of
attention
and perhaps
my desire now to kind of discipline my
curiosity into questions is me casting
off what was
once me
very much being kind of selfish when it
came to these sorts of conversations it
was all about me me me
and now this is me almost going in the
polar opposite direction
and still finding joy in that i don't
find it awkward at all it's like a
little bit of the old me comes out when
i get to talk like this where i get to
indulge and it's my turn it's me in the
line
right um right but i genuinely do enjoy
creating a platform that allows whoever
i'm speaking to to be at their absolute
best
like a ton of things that i give as
advice to other podcasters
stuff for instance that the audience
will never see like
when i'm on a skype call with someone
i'll nod
all the time just as they're talking
i'll just keep on nodding like this
like that churchill dog in the back of
the car like just constantly going away
because i want the other person to feel
comfortable and confident like that
you're encouraging yeah i i hear you
this is what you're saying keep on going
mate keep on going mate that sounds good
that sounds good um
so i love i love doing that and that has
been a really interesting transformation
and there may be
i think it's perhaps something that
young guys get a lot this sort of male
posturing when you're
you know you break out of your teens
into your 20s you want to be a
an alpha guy you want to be attractive
you want to be confident and charismatic
and you can often mistake brashness
and over self-sufficiency for that
and i think yeah by far whether it's
trying to get laid or trying to make
mates like having
curiosity genuine curiosity and what
other people say it was enough that a
bunch of different people at a party who
were drunk
highlighted like what the [ __ ] are you
doing asking questions
so do you ever encounter people who
really don't
open up to you and how do you deal with
that being honest my sample size for
how long i've been doing this is
probably not that big
right how long have you been doing this
18 months i'd guess speaking like this
consistently
yeah um and
yeah i think that was definitely one of
the things again any sort of budding
aspiring podcasters out there
if you're not used to asking questions
that's probably the first skill
that you need to learn that it's your
job to just get that curiosity
turn it into like a pharmaceutical
nuclear grade weapon
and fire it at the other person as much
as possible um
yeah so i i sometimes people don't want
to open up
in person but you kind of get that
impression if you're not on the same
wavelength anyway if you're not
vibrating at the same frequency you kind
of
sense that but i think it's very hard i
find it hard as a therapist um
when people won't open up to me it's
something i've had to learn
is that not frustrating it is and
and i also find it socially as well it's
something i've had to
endure and and respect because not
everyone is open
and that's okay i don't need to hit it
off and
connect incredibly deeply with everyone
but that's something i've definitely had
to learn and be patient about
and i don't know if you find that as
well that sometimes you don't
you don't engage as intensely you don't
have
a deep rapport with absolutely everyone
absolutely yeah
so do you ever ask people questions
where they just kind of
avoid or don't go further
don't take the conversation anywhere and
and you have to deal with that
yeah sometimes i think my capacity to
deal with awkwardness is actually fairly
low and that's something i've had to
learn
to deal with as well that
sitting with silence and sitting with
awkwardness as a podcaster
or just a conversationalist is something
i really didn't like i think it was born
out of a
rooted lack of confidence in my own
ability uh either as
sort of socially or as a podcaster
and silence to me meant
i'm not interesting or they're not
interested in me or i'm not
moving this conversation in the right
direction or they're going to think this
sucks or whatever it might be
and yeah for a long time sitting with
that silence
was the most uncomfortable thing and
then some episodes that we've done
this guy called daniel schmacktenberger
who is a ridiculous polymath
civilization engineer and we did this
two hour long episode where there was
30 second silences in there and i just
felt perfectly fine just sitting and
letting him think
and he's thinking and thinking because
that's the pace that he moves at
and that was really beautiful and people
commented on how nice it was to have
that silence themselves as listeners
and i'm like hang on a second like
there's two people in this conversation
and neither of them felt uncomfortable
with it and you don't even get to choose
as the listener when someone starts
speaking again and you felt comfortable
with it
so that really taught me a lesson about
how
silence is an important element of
talking to people too
and it can actually be used as a feature
rather than a bug
yes absolutely so do you find that
applies in social situations as well
a little bit more difficult um often
because it's not one-on-one
and in a big group especially the sorts
of circles that i'll sometimes traffic
in
there will be uh varying degrees of sort
of brashness charisma
outgoing extroversion and that
doesn't those sorts of people don't tend
to allow for a 30-second pause
you know for someone someone to consider
what the future civilization looks like
or whatever it is um
it's rare rarer yeah should i say
do you find that when you can hold back
you can actually learn a lot more
i think so um again
talking and not asking questions is on a
gradation
and further down from that is asking
questions too quickly and not giving the
other person time to speak i'm sure that
you
what's it called the use of silence or
whatever it is in therapy that you guys
use
sure the use of silence yeah well it's
just that i know that sitting and just
letting
the what are you called the client
patient
client client okay a patient makes it
sound a little bit dodgy doesn't it uh
well some therapists say patient i say
clean cool there's no there's no perfect
term i don't really love either actually
person person let the other person just
sit and think and then
whatever comes to the forefront of their
consciousness is what they say next
without you guessing what they want to
say
or something without rushing things
along or
crowding and i think silence sometimes
gives space
but it's about dosage because you don't
want to give someone so much space i i
went to a therapist once who was just
horribly withholding with the silence
and and it made me feel very
uncomfortable so i think it's about
finding
what fits but letting things emerge
and i guess if you're kind of crowding
someone conversationally i know for me
when i get too nervous i go into
question mode
where i use questions as a defense
not in therapy so much but in social
situations where i just start kind of
firing off questions and and it can be a
way of hiding
so i'm really really interested in what
questions say about ourselves
and as a question asker i'm now turning
it on you
so i'm doing the same thing i'm very
aware um but i'm owning it
and i feel like we have that in common
that we that we inquire
but where are we in all of that what
does that say about us
and what's it like to to be asked
questions
it's give and take so it's it's
interesting just to think about
where you are in all of this and and
what emerges from it
and and how you kind of find your sense
of self
by constantly turning to others like
where where does your voice come through
yeah again i i honestly think that this
last year or so
last 18 months particularly which has
been shaped by this project you know
again for all that i say to people to
try and find something that they love to
look at what they did when they were a
kid between the ages of 8 and 14 and
then consider that that some sort of
evolution of that might be their passion
as they get later into life what is it
that you can do for
just unencumbered joy um for all i say
that it's this kind of bottom up
emergent
way that you should try and find passion
this
show very much has top down affected the
person i am
in what i would say is a very positive
way um but it's like it's dictated or
it's influenced the
the path that i've gone in terms of my
own personal development i walk away
from the show
and i take so much of this with me i
take so much of the way that i operate
and hopefully that comes across you know
like i i want
to be i think this is one of the
beauties of having long-form
conversations that
people listen to regularly you know it's
three or four hours a week
of me doing this although it's not
usually me talking so much
and it's very hard to hide
you in that and for a very long time
as the listeners probably will be
familiar with i was living this kind of
metacognizant
uh playing a role egoic game and
it shines a very bright light on you um
when you have to speak this much
and it forces you to really think like
okay if i'm going to do this
if i try and play a persona i'm going to
be exhausted so i just need to be
rigorous and truthful
uh so yeah it's it's interesting but
again
there's there's kind of two juxtaposed
christopher's here one of them being the
the one that was probably very selfish
up until maybe specifically five years
ago
and then tapering up to like the last
sort of two years or so
and then this one which is very
different at least in terms of
conversation
do you ever get really tired of asking
questions or being curious
do you get bored and almost feel like
wow almost never so what what supplies
you with curiosity how do you
how do you keep that source
alive i'm not sure that i just don't
i don't see any other joy there is no
greater joy to me than linking together
two concepts that i didn't previously
realize worked
like i'll find something out about
the way that social media algorithms
work or
the way that this particular
star gravity time dilation happens when
it
goes into a neutron or star or whatever
it might be
anything whenever i learn any of this
stuff or a little
aphorism about life or anything i adore
it and it makes me
incredibly happy and i think
i wonder how much of that so here's
something that i was going i was going
to bring up with you obviously with your
insights into psychology
was that how much do you think
of the personal development world the
personal growth
self-development movement that we're
seeing at the moment
is people using
that to hide from the
person that they don't like deep down so
if you say i don't like me as i am now
but if i continue to grow every day
between now and the day that i die
perhaps the person that i turn into
might be acceptable and worthy of love
how often do you think it is that you
come across people like that
it's a really interesting question i i
like to think that
carl rogers was right in saying that
it's a paradox we have to accept who we
are in order to make changes
so i think that self-acceptance is often
a part of growth
and it's the same conversation in a way
if that makes sense
yeah i get it it's something i've been
thinking about so much this year
that i have some friends that
i think their desire for growth comes
from a really good
place i think it comes from a place of
just wanting to be better without
feelings of insufficiency that's driving
it but i
also think that there is a huge group
perhaps even the majority
maybe not but perhaps even the majority
of people
who are tumbling down the personal
growth
rabbit hole in a desperate attempt to
try and find a person who they are going
to be proud to look in the mirror and be
um i read this quote the other day about
how
people who have a a low sense of
self-worth can sometimes
find in development a hope
a hope for a better future basically
does that make sense
i that makes a lot of sense and i think
i think that you're on to something
really important which is especially
prevalent during the pandemic there's a
huge amount of pressure to
self-actualize
and the wellness industry the well-being
industry i
suggests that we have to constantly be
updating improving progressing
growing and actually what about
self-acceptance
so i think there is that sense of coming
to therapy thinking fix me
and that can hide as i want to develop
and grow but actually
sometimes celebrating where you are
already is is a profoundly important
thing and and i think people can come to
therapy and
discover that actually what they thought
was a flaw turns out to be a strength
so well i'll give you one example
although you're totally doing your thing
and turning this around on me i see how
you did that
but if you if you can see i'm wearing a
necklace which
is a ram with horns
a therapist i went to one said to me
and i think quite an unkind way
you are like a ram with horns and i
think she meant it as an insult it was
an intervention and i decided to take it
as a compliment
and i began collecting rams with horns
and i i love rams with horns when i was
in italy
recently i saw rams with horns and i
related to them and
felt like we were one one of the things
i took from that therapy was accidental
she didn't
mean for me to take it it's not what i
thought i would get from it but i
arrived
in therapy thinking i need to let go of
this
aspect of myself and i left thinking
actually that's part of who i am
i don't really want to change that what
is it what is a rhyme with hans
it means that i can be quite
attached to certain things and i
probably
get very assiduous about certain certain
issues
and and struggle to let things go and
around the thorns
i mean it can be a good thing it can be
a bad thing so there are times where i
absolutely need to let go
and not fixate and not obsess but there
are times where i think i'm very
passionate
and conscientious and i will go above
and beyond for something and that's part
of who i am so it's a strength and a
weakness
but it's not it's not just one or the
other and i've decided to kind of
embrace that aspect
of myself so i think sometimes
celebrating our flaws
is a massive victory and
and it can take a lot of work to get
there
it's a kind of journey for many i know
it's an overused term to say journey
but i didn't always realize that i liked
being a rainbow horns
and actually when she said it to me i
probably felt initially quite offended
and hurt
but no longer well i mean a perfect
example of that is i think i would have
probably been called nosy
as a kid there you go so same here
totally totally relating to that one and
what's nosiness like you roll that
forward and then you discipline it down
you make it a little bit
you put a bow on it you make the rough
edges a little bit less rough
i really do think one of the things i'd
love everybody to take away is
the um barbell or the the two-sided coin
paradox that is strength and weakness
either you know being nosy as a kid
definitely another are you sensitive as
a kid of course
and most therapists are i think
some are insensitive maybe but yeah i
was told i was sensitive and and that
felt like a weakness and now it's a
strength
absolutely um empathy is one i know it's
very trendy now for children to be
taught empathy
i i don't remember thinking that it was
an advantage because i felt things
acutely and i would hear about an
upsetting story and it would really get
under my skin and stay with me
and i didn't know how to kind of process
it and
and now i've i've managed to make use of
it because actually caring
it is a really good thing in in my world
but
i i sometimes cared in a way that felt
disproportionate as a child
and do you cry at like uh
romantic christmas movies and like
beautiful sort of sad
i i felt it all i still feel a lot
yeah but understanding that that
strong feelings can actually be a
wonderful
life enhancing thing has taken time for
me
yeah there was a question asked by an
audience member when i went to go and
see jordan peterson live in manchester a
couple of years ago
uh and the question boiled down to the
depth of my consciousness causes me to
suffer
i'd prefer to be ignorant like my dog
than have to the the yeah
it's both a blessing and a curse to feel
everything so very deeply oh yeah
um and i i
i understood the question and i really
sort of empathized with the question as
well
but we don't have that luxury we don't
have that choice it's like
um the allegory of the cave do you know
that plato's allegory of the cave
um so i advise anyone who doesn't know
what that is to just go and go on
youtube and learn about it it's
basically taking the red pill that once
you see
something you can't see it once you
learn something you can't unlearn it
and that's the beautiful thing about
having a conversation that when someone
convinces you of something
it's it's like it's literally like a
parasite in your brain but hopefully one
that's good
someone convinces you of something you
can no longer be unconvinced
and um yes
i think that the depth of experience
giving you that richness in life is
something
that can cause people to have turmoil
right like it can hurt it
hurts to feel
things that you know other people
probably don't even notice
that way that that person glanced at you
that
slight shoulder turn or the fact that
they
hugged everybody else and just gave you
a handshake when they left or whatever
it might be all of these little things
and even just the fact that i noticed
this stuff like these are all
examples that i've seen not on me but in
other people in the last
month because i've been around i'm not
used to being around so many people i
was just like hyper social for four
weeks
and all i'm doing is observing just
looking at stuff but what's that that's
a nosiness coming through again
that's the curiosity that's the
hyper vigilance i would call it too yeah
perhaps
perhaps um i'm trying to think about
some of the other things
so certainly coming from a working-class
town in the north of the uk
i i don't have the accent and again at
the time that was a weakness it was
something that made me stand out at
school
in a definitely a sub-optimal manner uh
but that has led now to
me having an accent that can be
understood by americans like you which
is useful well
so next up on my list for things that
felt like a weakness that are now
strength i'm really loving this list
being an outsider yeah feeling like an
outsider in my childhood was very
uncomfortable
and and i wanted to fit in and now i
take pride
i i don't necessarily have to match
everyone else that doesn't mean i have
to be kind of
provocative and make a point of always
being an outsider it's also great to
connect and
feel like i belong but actually
accepting
difference can can be a wonderful thing
and i kind of wish i could say that to
my younger self i don't know if you ever
feel like absolutely like one i want to
probably one of them the most important
things if i could send it
you know like a couple of sentence email
it would be
to embrace weirdness
your weakness is your competitive
advantage i've said this a million a
million million times
um and your previous business partner mr
de botton um he has this fantastic video
why we're fated to be lonely
and he says that loneliness is the kind
of tax we have to pay to atone for a
certain complexity of mind
given the choice between honesty and
acceptability most of us choose the
latter
but that very much is your
unique route to never being
competed against and that comes to
within business
career it comes for personally
everything
if you decide no one else can ever be
you no no one can beat you at being you
um and the the sooner that you can
embrace that as not just a nice sort of
pithy aphorism that
reminds you if you're feeling a little
bit cast out that it's okay mate
like that it it genuinely is the truth
as i've embraced
my um weirdness
and the fact that i don't necessarily
fit into an archetype as tons and tons
and tons of people do
they they all feel this and they nerf
the edges they round off the edges of
the interesting stuff that they do in
life to try and make themselves fit into
the bell curve of what normal is
um but as george mcgill a buddy that i
went to dubai with said
if you're trying to be normal by
definition you're regressing to the mean
normal people get normal results
extraordinary people get extraordinary
results
like we all want somehow everybody wants
to both be
the most popular most liked person on
the planet
and also elon musk or conor mcgregor or
you know like one of the like
kardashians or something
and you think you don't get it both ways
those people have
ridiculous outcomes because they have
ridiculous inputs
and you can choose one but you can't
choose both right
so let's go back to you if we can
tell us something disturbing something
surprising
take a risk it doesn't have to be the
big trauma with the capital t
maybe trauma with the lowercase t
um so i've certainly sort of
realized a lot it kind of following on
from what we just said there
realized a lot that the sort of insights
that i've got by
by being an outsider are very liberating
and very enjoyable
um but at the time just felt like such a
curse
like i just didn't fit in i couldn't i
remember
i used to think about
how other people dressed or find
bizarre quirks and how groups of people
that i wanted
to them to like me what i thought it was
they were
doing that was binding them together as
a group it's like oh it's because they
were all wearing like
skinny jeans and i was throwing loose
fitting jeans or it's because they all
walk this way to school or i walk that
way to school or whatever it might be
um and i think that for a long time i
was just confused by a lack of
acceptance
especially as a young kid and again
without necessarily a brother or a
sister or someone who's kind of
either always got your back and or can
teach you
the common rules of socializing
um that was
that's really only something kind of
like realizing the impact that my
childhood had on me
is very very much only something that
i've come back to
and in a way it's really
i find it fascinating i really enjoy
tracking the line
tracing the route that different
elements of me has walked and everyone
that's listening can think the same like
everything that you are now is
the flower that's grown out of a seed of
something that was planted when you were
much younger
again another school of life video is
where they talk about
bad inner voices and they say all bad
inner voices will want a bad outer voice
um and when you hear the way that you
criticize yourself for
under achieving an x or not being good
enough at why or
the the shame that you feel when you
make a blunder sort of socially whatever
it might be
a lot of those voices if you listen
closely enough they're spoken in a
cadence of someone that you can remember
from when you were much younger
sure so for you let's get specific let's
get personal
i don't know being honest like this is
why i asked you to be my therapist and
you said that we know each other too
well and you won't do it
um but being i haven't done this work
there is a
but there's work to be done oh yeah
there's tons and i find it interesting
like i genuinely have embraced
the opportunity to delve into the into
these sort of deeper areas of myself
but i i don't know like i can listen a
lot i can listen
quietly enough to know that it's a
familiar voice but i don't really know
what the amalgamation of everything is
and um yeah but that was an interesting
insight you know i've got a lot to thank
your previous uh job at the school of
life
for these insights that have sort of
rolled forward and allowed me to
to see this sort of stuff um but yeah i
i don't
i don't think that i know i can't
pick it apart it's like a very messy
sort of soundtrack at the moment and the
texture of my mind
when i try and get to that place is
something that that requires more work
it's like a glass ceiling and a glass
floor that i
i can't really get past just yet but see
what what you've done is
really brave actually because you have
said i don't know
which is a really honest part of any
emotional
discovery that there is that bit of mess
and uncertainty and kind of unknowing
that's part of learning and growing so
that's that's a
really genuine aspect of this process
and and of course this is not therapy
and direct it won't be your therapist
but
we can have intense deep conversations
of course but
i think i think it's really important to
not have it all be tidy and resolved and
there can be a sense that
emotional epiphanies happen overnight
and it's a creative process
and any creative process requires stages
and steps
and a bit of mess and experimenting
given that we're talking about questions
at the moment have you got any of the
favorite questions that you
like to ask your clients is like
opening questions that people who are
listening can
ask themselves or maybe to sort of take
away from this and ruminate on over the
next
while sure i mean i don't encourage
ruminating but
sure um tell me about a
time that you thought you couldn't
survive and
tell me about what got you to the other
side or if you have gotten to the other
side
that's a cool question it's not a
question i always ask but
i am asking you uh i can definitely take
one from this year that
going into the i ruptured my achilles
three and a half months ago and as
someone who
sometimes has catastrophic thinking i
just presumed
that it would go badly i didn't think i
had a particularly good constitution
to be resilient in that sort of
situation
you know if if i can get sad and upset
when there's
ostensibly nothing wrong when there's
really something wrong just how [ __ ]
am i going to be
um and i think i just presumed i was a
lot more fragile than i
was um fascinating yeah it was
interesting i i found
in myself a room it was like living in a
house for your entire life and finding a
door to a room that you didn't know
existed and you open it
and it's like a [ __ ] bunker and it's
lead lined and there's a shotgun in
there and you can
take on a lot it was very endogenous it
came out of somewhere inside of me
um and i think that that's reassuring
for people who think
that maybe they don't have the
resilience they see people who go
through much much worse things than i do
you know people who've been
like human trafficked or captured by
terrorists or
you know lost both of their legs have
been terminally ill all of this sort of
things
um there is certainly something
inside me and presumably other people as
well
because i heard these stories right you
hear about this person
had his arms stuck under a rock in the
middle of the desert for 72 hours with
no water and he
survived and then did a ultra marathon
back to whatever and you see people like
david gordon's getting after it
and you think like what like what on
earth is wrong with these people i'm
never going to be like them
but kind of when reality comes a
knocking
there is something that answers and that
for me was um
that was a really interesting insight
this year that's probably one of the
things i'm proudest about out of this
year obviously i'm happy with
how this project's gone and other bits
and pieces but certainly my response the
way i responded
is one of the things i'm most proud of
so just to recap
you thought you were less capable
less resilient less robust precisely
and actually you've gotten to the other
side and when something really did go
wrong you were able to handle it
yeah how encouraging yeah pretty much so
i'm bolstering but it makes me think
like what
on earth was going on why am i why was
there periods during my 20s
where i wouldn't be able to get out of
bed for days on end
just crushed under the weight of
existence
when there was nothing wrong so
sure i mean it's it's really interesting
how there are times in life when
stepping in a puddle is traumatic
and other times when you have a true
disaster
and and you can actually deal with it
and i think sometimes it's harder when
things aren't going wrong
and and you're just feeling a kind of
despair
so i feel for the person in you where
everything was ostensibly going okay and
you were really suffering
just carrying the weight of existence
that's still hard
in some ways harder because the world
couldn't even see what was wrong
and you didn't even have any explanation
for what was happening
yeah the the shame around depression was
something that i
took it took me an awfully long time to
deal with that
especially because of the asymmetry we
see online now that
we are we all now not only have to live
up to other people's ideals but the
ideal that we've set for ourselves on
our own social media channel right
like you put yourself across as x y and
z
and then one day you're [ __ ] the
batman symbol
and you think oh hang on like i'm
supposed to be x y or z here and
you you have to try and compensate and
yeah i was so ashamed like the fact why
am i in bed like why can't i get out of
bed why can't i feel good about life
i haven't got any problems oh yeah
hugely and obviously those thought loops
kind of make everything worse
um and i can rationalize you know i've
got advice i've given advice to tons and
tons of people of how
i tried to try and deal with depressive
episodes
but at the time it just feels like
drowning in thoughts like that's what
depression feels like it feels like
you're drowning
under the weight of your own
consciousness and it's such a
it's such a heavy situation to exist in
that it really doesn't surprise me
how getting out of bed can
feel like it takes a superhuman effort
you know opening opening the curtains
requires the world's strongest man to
give you a hand with it
totally it's really interesting in the
course of five minutes i feel like
you've already changed gears in your
attitude towards that
time in your life because first you said
at first you kind of made light of it
and you said
you you couldn't really cope with life
at the time but then you were able to
cope with your achilles
i i feel like you've now become more
compassionate to that
to that inner self yeah maybe i think
there's probably a bit of uh defense
mechanism that goes in there that if you
can be flippant about a situation that
once gave you trauma that you kind of
don't remind yourself
of that but one of the one of my
favorite episodes that i've done on the
show was
my experience with depression a few
years ago now um
and that i continue to get messages
all the time from people who listen to
that and
the insight i think
i haven't heard many conversations from
people
where they've dealt with depression and
it's been just
just because you know it's not the grand
needed to go a rehab overdosed on drugs
cheated on my girlfriend got kicked out
of the house got found by the no
situational stressor
but not even that just that it's not
it's not there's no glory or grandeur or
even narrative behind it
yeah that that to me is the real
pain i think of depression in the 21st
century that it can be
so comfortable it can be so unremarkable
unremarkable depression and you just
think
what why do i feel bad
why do i feel this way what is it about
me why am i not strong enough to be able
to get past this why am i
dealing with these thoughts that i why
am i thinking i'm just thinking the same
thing over and over and i'm
the more that i think it the more that i
spend this time here the more that i
hate myself the more that i wish that it
wasn't the
the case um and it's a a level of
depression that doesn't end it's not got
suicidal ideations in it
it's not got that level of it's less
eventful it's just it's totally
unremarkable
um what would you say to that
time in your life to that person you
were it was a long time you know
like it doesn't i still don't
in the cold light of day as we are now
it's very easy to think with the
the comfort of rationality right um
you are so illogical in that situation
so unbelievably detached from
what's actually happening uh and
sometimes this can be triggered by like
something so small
and you know all of the practical
implications
that i have which are a couple of step
process that you need to break
down the things that you need to do in
the steps so small that even you can do
them which is
i need to get out of bed okay first off
i need to pull the covers off me i need
to put my right foot on the floor then
my left foot on the floor then i need to
stand up
so you can break things down in that way
and that's a practical way um
a warm shower a walk call a friend and
have a big glass of water
like those things will fix so much of
the way that you feel
um but when you can't get out of bed or
when you feel like you can't get out of
bed
um and you just want to hide under the
covers from
reality or existence
that that feels very very far away so i
don't
i don't really know i don't think
the solution is the rationality and
giving yourself a
aphoris psychological
solution to this also doesn't work
because you're not
thinking sufficiently clearly to be able
to lean on that
george again tweeted something that said
uh telling someone to think their way
out of overthinking is like telling
someone to snort their way out of a
cocaine addiction
that's very smart like that
um so disputing it really doesn't help
because it feels like that and that's
that's the thing i think as well that
even even with a drug addiction people
can see from the outside in
you know like they can see that there's
some sort of physical dependency going
on here
if they took me in a lab and they
measured me they'd know there was
something wrong or
if i was actually skinned or i'd run out
of money or if i was actually
broken a bone or you know destitute
whatever it might be
it would feel more legitimate i think
it's the lack of legitimacy
this oh yeah bizarre bourgeois
[ __ ] you don't feel you have the
right
yeah who am i who am i to feel sad and
yeah that um
that was something that i think was
difficult to swallow as well
because even the stories that were given
of depression
are these ones of grandeur uh this
conversation with a
a buddy one of the very early episodes a
guy called mike cashew
and um i asked him whether or not he
thought he he was
addicted to heroin and cocaine by the
age of 14. he was an alcoholic by the
age of 16.
and um he bounced back to now be the ceo
of this hugely successful company he won
the crossfit games
twice um but i asked him if he hadn't
hit rock bottom whether he would still
be there
and it's this
not not good
not great not average but just sort of
ambient dissatisfaction with life sort
of
vacillating between just okay enough
to think that life's all right down
to kind of existential bit of pain
and then wobbling back up again um that
really
doesn't give anyone the activation
energy to bounce out of the bottom
um and i wonder i wonder whether
sometimes a breakdown can actually be
quite useful in that way
oh i think so
but i think you're also really onto
something with the kind of scolding that
goes on
internally the the telling off
for you don't have a right to feel this
way
um it's so it's so persecutory it's so
self-loathing
on top of everything else and and i
think it sounds like anger turned
inwards it really does there's a
it's an it's probably very quickly
it becomes the majority of the weight
that you're trying to bear
i think the self-referential the
narrative about the narrative
yeah um because the first thing only
exists whatever it is that kicks off the
bad mood
that that first thing only ever exists
for just you know a fleeting
conversation meeting day concern
whatever it might be
and then after that it's the thoughts
about thoughts
and the feelings about feelings i i
often see this in therapy you have the
primary emotions which
which just happen for various reasons
and they're fine whatever they are but
it's often the secondary emotions that
are so
tricky so i feeling angry at yourself
for feeling sad
and kind of coming in with the judgment
so it's often looking at the the
secondary emotions that
can be really helpful for then just
accepting the primary emotions if that
makes sense
so you said think about a time when you
thought you couldn't survive
and then think about how you did what's
another one
another one another question that people
can
not ruminate on that people can
enjoyably think about
what would you say to the most fragile
part of yourself
oh that's a good one
i think i take things very seriously i
take life very seriously
it's a function of someone who thinks a
lot
because small incidents
get magnified up to take up more room
than they deserve
i've certainly noticed this and other
people who spend a lot of time in
solitude in fact
probably everybody throughout 2020 will
notice that
small incidents whether good or bad will
have probably had a disproportionate
effect on them
because they've had the time to ruminate
totally totally that's why i
when you said ruminate it i had to come
in reflect
yeah but because ruminating is just
so huge right now um and and we're in
the kind of
zoom gloom and we don't have the normal
camaraderie and incidental banter that
helps to fuse things and we feel
paranoid
we get a weird email we get a weird text
and then it just grabs hold
and takes up residence and that's really
powerful
that power of diffusery humor is
something that i've almost totally
forgotten about um which sounds stupid
but
especially this year the number of times
where something something's happened and
you can just laugh it off
like i was talking to a sas operative
a couple of weeks ago and he was saying
that the use of
very dark humor in the special forces is
one of the ways that they deal with
bad situations makes total sense he's
been next to guys who've been taking
fire and one of them's been shot in the
arm
and he'll start laughing and everyone
will start laughing
and you think i mean gallow humor
yeah makes sense yeah very much so so
next question what would you say to your
102 year old
self what what has worked in your life
what has success meant to you
that's still something that i think is
i'm working out i i think that
when you do a ton of self-work which
i've done over the last
few years and hopefully as more people
listen to the show they
kind of get dragged through that
world as well um
i would find it difficult to work out a
trajectory for me because i think i'm
still a
quite an inflection point um
i get really jealous that's one thing
that i do get interestingly jealous
about
is whenever i meet people that have very
concrete senses of where they want to be
longer term um i was talking to this guy
while i was in dubai who said
you know that is man like he's an
architect he's doing all of these
different things
making a ton of money like very
successful young guy as well
he's like you know what it is man like
i'm loving what i'm doing at the moment
but i just can't wait to own a bar on a
beach
with my wife and my couple of kids in
somewhere totally clear plan
and i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
like why
how how i was that and i had to call it
out i was like dude that's
that's an incredibly precise
well-defined plan and i didn't think
that he was
postulating at all i didn't think that
this was him putting on a facade like he
just said it like it was a fact
like drop the apple it falls to the
floor and i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm so jealous of that
like i've never been i've never been
certain about
sort of long term what that is
um so lots of question marks yeah which
is
which is beautiful and great for my 102
year old self there are lots of question
marks there are some qualities
that matter for a good rich life
but it's not too specific i think it's
good to keep these things loose
and and allow space
as well space for surprise discovery
growth
i think you're right uh you used a word
that brings us to our next question
jealousy when was the last time
you felt incredibly jealous
that certainly comes to mind that
incident that i said there with someone
who has this
this super sort of tight trajectory i
mean i i think everybody feels envy on
an almost
second by second basis when they look at
social media right like i've come back
to the uk now and all of my buddies that
i was out there where they're still out
in dubai and i think oh
like it's so nice and warm out there but
this is something i've certainly
realized that
the grass is always greener for us as
humans
and this stems from evolutionary
psychology that
humans aren't built to be happy they're
built to be effective we're literally
wired to be to find life unsatisfactory
because if the first time
you had sex you'd never had sex again if
the first time that you ate you'd never
hunt food again
you need to eat the deer and it just not
actually be quite as nice as you thought
you need to have sex and it just kind of
make you feel a little bit less
fulfilled than you thought it was going
to be
there's this this quote i can't remember
who the philosopher is he says
um after copulation the devil's laughter
can be heard
and there's a concept there's a
medical diagnosis for men that get
brief acute existential crises after
they've come
and to the men who are suffering without
their listening like it's not just you
but it's just a really hilarious way
that our genes
influence our emotions because it's
adaptive
it means that we're more likely to
survive and reproduce which is really
all we're here for
um so yes i think that jealousy pops up
fairly consistently for me when i see
things
and and another part of it i think
is stems from an insecurity around not
being all that i could be
that you think it's almost a jealousy
for an imagined world in which i was
fulfilling my potential
so you're you're self-envious yeah very
much so
i think i'd like look at the world i
could have if only
i wasn't spending as much time on my
phone
not getting up until seven i could be
getting up at six or i could be going to
bed at
whatever i should be reading rather than
watching tv actually you're
you're competing with your ego ideal
precisely
that's a really interesting and
insidious competition that happens all
the time that we don't talk about enough
where you are constantly looking at the
kind of
activated potentiated you and falling
short and and it plays out all the time
i think in life i don't mean you
specifically i just mean human beings
yeah so thank you for offering offering
that up
you've been incredibly open today and
you have
actually spoken quite bravely and
vulnerably
thank you can we try and recap the
questions for people
so that they can remember what we went
through yeah absolutely so
question one can we
list some traits that felt like flaws
in our childhoods but actually turn out
to be strengths
so identify those weaknesses and turn
them around
into sources of success
second question can you
think of a time in your life that you
didn't think you could survive that felt
traumatic and maybe unbearable and
what helped you get to the other side
third question what would you say to
the most fragile part of yourself
fourth question what would you say to
your 102 year old self
fifth question can you describe
a time when you felt incredibly jealous
that's cool okay
thank you so much for being so open and
brave and
and walking the walk well thank you for
being here
i'm glad that you bullied me into doing
this and it's
completely blindfolded led me into the
room and then decided to do this
um do we know when
you're going to complete writing your
book oh i'm i'm
handing it in in may okay and
how long is that is that like six months
from then until publish
um i it'll be published early 2022.
cool well depending on depending on how
brave you managed to get me over the
next year we may be back on to
do a similar episode and then you will
absolutely be back on to talk about that
i really appreciate your friendship i
absolutely love the fact that we met
each other a year ago and i'm very very
glad
that uh you you pushed me into doing
this today
same here it's such a pleasure i i did
want to tell you what
led me to want to ask you all of these
questions as well which was
an aesop fable i could have said this at
the beginning
um it's it's one of my favorite fables
and i was
actually reading it to my six-year-old
son the other night
and there's a mother crab who is
lecturing her
baby crab on the importance of walking
straight
and the baby crab says but mom you're
walking sideways
and i think it's a really beautiful
powerful story i think of as a therapist
all the time
of kind of doing as we say practicing
what we preach
so it just made me think you're
constantly asking questions you're very
good at digging deep
um i've been on the receiving end of
that you you bring out
interesting quirky idiosyncratic
encounters
all the time and what is the life for
you of
of being that question asker
i wanted to just have a sense of your
interior world so thank you for
allowing us to see it thank you
[Music]
you